many Americans are losing patience with
statewide shelter and place orders we
don't have months or weeks you know
businesses are hurting County Supervisor
Jim Desmond has been fighting a losing
battle to reopen businesses in San Diego
who's hurt the most in this are the poor
people the people that rent the people
that work in a hospitality sector in the
restaurant a lot of single moms we had
our meeting the other day we have people
got on the phone crying hey I got a kid
to feed several southern states and
Colorado have started lifting or
significantly loosening orders when you
close somebody's business down and take
the livelihood and they are literally at
the face of losing everything I'm
willing to give them the benefit of the
doubt other governors are holding firm
but if we pull back too quickly those
numbers will go through the roof let's
go from essential now question not what
is essential but what is safe there's no
date if there's a date then we're
denying the facts on the ground we're
denying the reality of the spread of the
virus which is dynamic have the lockdown
saved lives
there's a debate over how to analyze the
data lockdowns just don't alter behavior
all that much economists Lyman Stone
says there's no correlation between the
timing of statewide or regional shelter
and place orders and a decline in the
kovat 19 death rate we can basically
build a theory and assert that the world
obeys our theory and just go looking for
any scrap of evidence that supports it
or we can start by looking at what are
the trends we actually observe Stone
looked at the date government such as
France issued shelter in place orders
compared to the total daily deaths 20
days later the minimum amount of time it
would take for exposure to the virus to
lead to a death in every case he found
the decline came long before the 20-day
threshold Lyman says that according to
the data voluntary social distancing is
effective people were already socially
distancing before the lockdown social
distancing works so we have a couple
different data sources that basically
track your cell phone which is a little
bit creepy and what we can see is that
policy choices like shelter and place
orders had almost no impact on when
people began to socially distance
California was able to lower their
caseloads significantly and the number
of deaths by quite a bit
by putting this regulation in place
economist Andrew fritzen co-authored a
working paper for the National Bureau of
Economic Research that concluded
California's lockdown
was effective and may have prevented
more than 1600 kovat deaths
California's location where this could
have gotten really bad really quickly
essentially what we did is we took a
weighted average of other states based
on characteristics of those states that
make them look like California we looked
at states that had similar growth rates
to California and said okay of the
states that did not put on a
shelter-in-place order within a certain
number of days and then compare that to
what happened in California the funny
thing is that they find that their
shelter in place order reduced deaths
beginning four days after it was
implemented which means that you must
assume that a considerable share of
kovat cases die four days after
infection the problem is that's not even
long enough for the incubation time in
part they're absolutely right that
individual behavior in social distancing
behavior started to change before these
lock downs changed what the shelter in
place orders it and what our paper
estimates is that there's this
additional bump that you get from
forcing the part of the population
that's not going to comply to comply
with the legal weight what makes these
numbers particularly slippery is that
it's difficult to know how many of the
job losses are temporary and come back
when the disease is defeated or come
back when the order is lifted it's also
unclear how many of these lives saved
are just deaths that are delayed I think
the job of the economist is to tell you
what the trade-off is and then the job
of the policymaker is to decide what
them and their constituents are
comfortable with Stone says what did
likely flatten the curve was in fact
information
declaring public emergencies correlated
increased voluntary social distancing
and the closure of schools and
cancellation of large gatherings also
appear to have slowed the spread he says
that instead of shelter-in-place orders
the rest of the world should learn from
the approach taken by Hong Kong which
never issued a shelter-in-place order
and has just four documented Cova deaths
we should not hesitate to pull the
trigger on closing borders second mask
early masks often everyone should wear a
mask and they should do so as soon as
you know that you have a threat of a
pandemic information is the most
powerful tool getting people to
understand the risk and protect
themselves but after that centralized
quarantine anyone who is a positive test
in any close contact of a positive test
we need to isolate them the majority of
US states have now significantly
modified their shelter in place orders
even California which never came close
to seeing its hospitals overrun began
allowing more retailers to reopen for
curbside pickup on May 8th but remains
committed to a largely top-down
technocratic approach unfortunately life
comes with some risks I think we're at a
point where showing we're declining in
numbers to me it looks like the
goalposts keep moving back you know we
shut these businesses down in a day why
is it taking us so long to open them
back up I understand we want to be safe
we want to be prudent but we need to
start
you